[Music]
humans have been using plants and fungus
has changed the experience of
consciousness for a very long time
nine thousand year old cave paintings
depict rituals with psychedelic
mushrooms psychedelics were often used
in religious ceremonies as sacraments of
her divination and healing it wasn't
until the mid 20th century that science
got with the program early psychedelics
research transformed neuroscience we
began treating five patients for 26 days
in clinical trials psychedelics like LSD
showed extraordinary potential it's an
important drug and treatment of mental
and emotional disorders these substances
rose from obscurity to miraculous
promise in a matter of years dangerous
deadly disastrous consequences all the
sudden there are these scare stories in
the media hyped by the government
there's propaganda suicide almost all
Moab normal any psychedelics were soon
perceived as a threat to public safety
and global stability it's a very
dangerous they're looking to drop today
to sign a drug bill and by the early 70s
essentially the research has stopped
the Golden Age of psychedelic science
was over but this story began in 1943 a
young Swiss chemist named Albert Hofmann
is working as a pharmaceutical company
in Switzerland tasked with formulating a
new stimulant Hofmann quite
inadvertently opened Pandora's box he
accidentally ingest what they called LSD
25 got it on his finger maybe in his eye
and started feeling strange he realized
there's something psychoactive in this
one three days later he ingest some
intentionally and realizes like oh [ __ ]
I'm losing it
Hoffmann was having the first acid trip
in the world so he and his lab assistant
taken one of the most famous bicycle
rides in history to his house where he
is separating from his body he's seeing
himself from the ceiling then he stepped
out in his garden and everything look
jeweled would do as if it were the first
day of creation and that is how LSD was
discovered commemorated on April 19th as
bicycle day
[Music]
Sandoz the company Hoffman worked for
provided lsd-25 for free to scientists
around the world
they basically unleashed this
open-source research effort where they
offered huge amounts of it to any
researcher basically with a nice piece
of stationery
[Music]
it was LSD that catalyzed our
understanding of neurotransmitters and
receptors and also the development of
other psychiatric drugs clinical
researchers investigated LSD as a
treatment for a wide range of mental
illnesses they looked at obsession
anxiety depression they looked
especially at alcoholism and had a 50
percent success rate which is quite
remarkable psychedelics became a
standard tool in psychotherapy it would
help people speed the process of
bringing their subconscious to where you
could discuss it worthy of therapists
there was a lot of this going on in the
fifties there was a dark side to the
research as well both the military and
the CIA saw a great potential see I
ain't got very interested first they
thought LSD might be a mind-control
agent or a booth serum
and then they thought well let's
weaponize it let's put it in the water
supply let's secretly give it to foreign
leaders to make them do and say stupid
things so is one crazy idea after
another awful awful stuff but it's what
was happening here at home that doomed
this research the drugs escaped the
laboratory and then Timothy Leary gives
a big push Harvard psychologist Timothy
Leary developed a dubious curriculum of
mind expansion and personal truth
through psychedelics a scandal erupts
he's fired from Harvard and then decides
to become the LSD evangelist turn on and
tune in and drop out he's essentially
saying everybody should use this drug
and the drug is taken up by the
counterculture
[Music]
richard nixon was convinced that he was
dealing with the threat from
psychedelics he called timothy leary
the most dangerous man in America the
kids would take LSD aren't gonna fight
you or they're not going to join your
corporations and here Timothy Leary and
Richard Nixon were in agreement so Nixon
passed the Controlled Substances Act in
1970 and that listed psilocybin and LSD
is no accepted medical use and a high
potential for abuse neither of which are
true and that's a remarkable event in
the history of science I don't know that
you can point to another time or episode
where you had a very promising line of
inquiry that has simply stopped for
reasons that have nothing to do with the
science and we lost 30 years of research
imagine what we would know now had we
been studying these compounds for those
30 years what we might have learned
about depression anxiety and addiction
consciousness and how the mind works
you
[Music]